just a couple of days ago i made a video
claiming that the iphone 14 pro would
finally get under display face id with a
brand new pill shaped cutout instead of
the notch which is a design we've been
seeing float around all over the
internet and as you can see in that
video's thumbnail i showed how the
system would work with the ambient light
sensor under the display like it already
is on the iphone 13 pro but with the
selfie camera their proximity sensor and
the infrared camera within the
pill-shaped cutout for maximum clarity
and then the dot projector and flood
illuminator would be going under the
display and the way apple would do that
is by placing them within this extra
hole on the side which is a design that
was originally leaked by shrimp apple
pro on twitter way back in the summer of
last year but the theory was that the
extra hole on the side would not be
visible at all leaving us with this
awesome looking pale shaped cutout like
you see in these custom renders that
shylesh on twitter made for me but
unfortunately it looks like i was
actually wrong and we're not getting
under display face id at all on the
iphone 14 pro so before you go down to
the comment section and destroy me give
me a chance to explain what happened and
what the actual design is more likely to
look like now the reason i was so sure
about under display face id coming to
the 14 pro
is because of an analyst named ross
young who has 25 years of experience in
the display industry and he's actually
the ceo of display supply chain
consultants so he's basically one of the
most qualified people in the display
world and that actually shows because he
currently has a 100
accuracy rating for apple leaks like
when he perfectly predicted the display
size and design of the ipad mini 6. or
the fact that he was the only one back
in october who claimed that the macbook
pros would have both mini led and 120
hertz pro motion refresh rate displays
and of course he was right again and
that finally brings us to the situation
with the under display face id on the
iphone 14 pro models when way back last
year he showed us this chart of the 2022
iphone 14 lineup which included the 14
pro and pro max models with under
display face id which is what my entire
video i made a couple of days ago was
based on but now he just came out with a
bombshell leak that completely flips the
script on what he was previously saying
with his firm now believing that the 14
pro models will have both a pill shaped
cutout and the extra circular cutout at
the same time with both of them being
fully visible and if you're wondering
why that extra hole has to be visible
it's likely because apple's tech isn't
quite ready to be put under the display
just yet more specifically the infrared
camera needs to be unobstructed since
it's scanning the ir dots and light from
both the dot projector and flood
illuminator and ray wong on twitter
mentioned an interesting point that
those two models can't be put under the
display because of pixelation since
they're going to be shining through
display pixels and i guess i was wrong
and thinking that it wouldn't matter and
even ross young himself said that
throwing the dot projector under the
display would be too risky so it's
unlikely that apple would be the first
company to introduce under display
infrared technology so because of all of
that it seems like apple is going to
have all of the face id sensors
including the selfie camera completely
unobstructed and that's why we need both
of those hole punch cutouts now getting
back to the actual design we've already
seen quite a few updated renders online
showing what it could potentially look
like and if you're wondering why all of
them are showing the extra circular hole
punch on the right side instead of the
left that's because way back in
september shrimp apple pro mentioned
that the display panel he leaked was
actually a photo taken of the backside
so if you flip it to the front the extra
hole would be on the right and that's
why everyone's renders have it on the
right side but in my personal opinion i
think that the leaked photo was actually
of the front of the display panel
because to me it makes much more sense
for the extra hole on the side to be
used for the selfie camera while all of
the face id sensors will be within the
pill shaped cutouts in the center and
even though ross young believes the hole
on the side is for the dot projector i
would have to disagree at this point in
time so let me explain my point of view
with the iphone 13 smaller notch
redesign apple made a very unusual move
which at the time didn't really make
sense for apparently no reason at all
they decided to move the selfie camera
from the right side of the notch over to
the left side for the first time in the
notches history and this was a really
weird change because apple gave no
reason for this and i personally had to
start reminding myself of the new camera
location on the left side when taking
selfies to be sure that i'm looking
directly into the camera and not off to
the side but now that ross young has
confirmed that the extra circular hole
punch is actually going to be visible
all of the puzzle pieces in my brain
have finally come together and it now
makes total sense if you take that
display panel leak and line it up with
the iphone 13 pros notch the selfie
camera on the 13 almost perfectly lines
up with the extra hole on the leaked
iphone 14 pro display panel so now apple
moving the selfie camera to the left
side finally makes sense now of course i
could be totally wrong about this but i
actually have two very good reasons for
the selfie cam being on the left instead
of within the pill shaped cutout on the
right first of all this would absolutely
be the path of least resistance for
apple since the selfie cam is already on
the left side on the iphone 13 so all
they would essentially have to do on the
14 pro is toss in the new panel with the
hole punch cutouts like we saw in shrimp
apple pros leaks and then take the same
exact glass panels from the iphone 13
lineup and remove the black paint from
the notch area and simply leave a little
bit of black paint around the hole punch
cutouts and bam they're done path of
least resistance and as for the second
reason i want to bring you guys back to
a tweet showing off the updated double
hole punch design one of the features
many believe apple might add back in is
the battery percentage indicator on the
top right of the display and i believe
that's actually much more likely to
happen if the extra hole punch is on the
left side instead because if you really
think about it the only thing on the
left side is the time and potentially a
location icon while the right side has a
cellular data the wi-fi signal and the
battery icon and the only way they'd
have room for the battery percentage is
if the extra hole punch actually goes on
the left so because of all of that i had
renders by shilesh update the previous
render to add in the extra hole on the
left side and in my opinion this looks
pretty great and by the way if you
haven't already followed him on twitter
go ahead and do that to thank him for
his awesome renders and now with that
said there is one more option that some
people on twitter are currently
discussing max weinbach mentioned that
apple could disable the display portion
between the two cutouts to make it a
long pill shaped cutout instead of
having dual cutouts but the problem i
have with this is that it would then
make it completely uncentered and it
would look kind of weird and i don't
think that apple would do this but of
course they could simply slide the whole
thing over to the side to make it
perfectly symmetrical and centered but
then that would mean that the display
panel leak from shrimp apple pro would
have to get tossed out completely since
only the peel shaped cutout is perfectly
centered in his league so in my opinion
i think that apple will go with this
design with two cutouts with the extra
circular cutout on the left side to
allow enough room on the right for the
battery percentage and the reason i
think apple would go with this design
is because it's completely unique and
you will never mistake the iphone 14 pro
for any other android smartphone which
is something that's very important to
apple as we've seen in the past with the
recent macbook pro notch design and of
course the legendary chin on the imac so
with that said if you think i'm
completely wrong about all of this then
let me know down in the comment section
below but if you agree with me then
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one and definitely
check out one of those two right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]